there are few things in life more
satisfying than landing a
long-range headshot in battlefield
[Applause]
that's the stuff but as a classic gun
sniper rifles tend to have kind of a
split identity in games
they can be simultaneously hard to use
and also incredibly overpowered they're
insanely deadly on tiny maps where they
shouldn't be
and given huge disadvantages on large
maps where they should shine
often they feel like some of the most
difficult weapons to use but then some
kid winds up posting a 360 no-scope
montage on youtube
in this video we're going to talk about
why sniper rifles are so hard to
translate to video games and why they
often wind up broken
if you guys like multiplayer shooters
head on over to gamespot's youtube page
where we have a ton of stuff for you to
watch like expert react videos
while you're there if you like what you
see please give us a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel
let's get into it what is a sniper rifle
for that we should bring in our
channel's favorite firearms expert
jonathan ferguson
a highly accurized rifle
designed for the purpose um firing a
cartridge of
a certain power level that enables you
to reach out to
really quite extreme ranges so beyond
800 meters
up to maybe even 2 000 meters with some
sort of an optical
sight with high magnification 12 power
20 power something like that
so that you can even identify your
target
at long range and then so that you can
put
a reticle on them put all put it put in
all of the data that you need to
the right clicks onto your scope to land
a precision
single shot at very long range that's
that's in essence what a sniper rifle
has to do and so it means that they
they're relatively easy
to define
seems pretty straightforward a rifle
with a big old optic that makes long
range shots
accurately so what's it used for a
sniper rifle is for
taking out things that are important to
the enemy team that could be the guy at
the back with a light machine gun
someone on an objective
an enemy sniper a high value target in
war zone a vehicle
or dispatching history's most evil
dictators in very painful fashion
all shot ball shot cross your fingers
and your balls
yeah go one testicle
easy enough right it's not supposed to
be that easy
turns out long range shooting is
actually very hard and developers don't
make sniper rifles realistic
because gamers don't want to become
physicists like you would have to
actually understand physics
i didn't tell you the full story earlier
when i said that sniper rifles are just
there to make long range shots
accurately
what i should have said was sniper
rifles are there to make the first shot
accurately
so the thing you're shooting at doesn't
shoot back having to fire multiple times
just gives away your position and lets
other players know where you are
and it takes a hell of a lot more than
you might think in real life to make
that first shot
we're not getting into it all in this
video but making a proper
long range shot involves some serious
physics math and a deep understanding of
the environment you're shooting in
some things you have to consider are
gravity wind range atmospheric pressure
temperature
altitude if your barrel's hot or cold
and even the spin of the entire goddamn
planet
at this distance you'll also have to
take the coriolis effect into account
that's assuming you are already very
familiar with your weapon system
have a consistently performing bullet
and know what the clicky clicky dials do
on the scope in the majority of games
players aren't going to take the time to
calculate the physics behind making that
shot because it's just not
fun or practical and let's be honest the
ranging games is usually too short to
even bother
maybe hardcore armor players y'all are a
different breed
but for the sake of argument let's say
you're a genius and you can do all this
perfectly on the fly or even just game
developers made sniper rifles
very easy to use when game developers
make sniper rifles too simplified
some players get very good with them and
they dominate other weapon classes in
unfair ways
getting domed out of nowhere is not very
fun for everyone else involved and that
leads developers to find odd compromises
and exaggerations to balance out sniper
rifles
some of which are not great let's talk
about scope lint
what in the absolute hell is scopeline
in video games it's like someone
attached a mega spotlight to their gun
skoklin is honestly the worst way to
make sniper rifles fair for starters it
negates any skill a player might have
sneaking somewhere to take that shot in
the first place which is the entire
purpose of a sniper it gives away your
position the second you even start
looking for targets and demolishes any
surprise or advantage you might have so
if you can't look through your scope for
targets without giving yourself away
then players resort to other tactics
like quickscoping which is even worse
because it leads to running gun snipers
that can drop players with massive
one-shot damage
while barely aiming and that gets around
all of the drawbacks of a sniper rifle
so what else have developers tried to
make sniper rifles fair
my personal favorite is bullet trace
it's where the shot from a sniper rifle
leaves a visible trail behind
from a game standpoint it rewards the
time players take to set up their
position and gives them the first shot
advantage much like in real life but
then to be fair to the other players it
gives away the direction the shot came
from that means a good sniper can make
quick follow-up shots but also a fast
reacting player can see where it's
coming from and do something about it
breathing is another exaggerated take on
balancing sniper rifles
like every time you sit down to shoot
you're huffing and puffing like you just
ran a marathon
which is probably more accurate than
soldiers never ever getting tired from
running all the time continuously for
matches for days
and the scheme of things is probably one
of the more harmless things to try
another compromise is old-fashioned
stats balancing which can be very
inconsistent
games often don't handle physics like
reality in the real world you have
constants around you like
gravity meaning everything is pulled to
the ground evenly a bullet fired from a
gun parallel to the ground
will hit at the same time as a bullet
dropped from the same height it's just
it does it very far away from you and
you can
more or less predict how far something
will go based on its speed
but in games developers don't have to
deal with a constant world and they can
tweak the physics of each gun
individually
almost as if each gun was living in its
own planet this can encompass things
like velocity
speed bullet drop and power to make
matters even more complicated
sometimes in the very same game you'll
have physical projectiles meaning you
have to lead the target to compensate
for travel time
and hitscan weapons that instantly
teleport bullets to the same target
if you want to know more about hitscan
vs physical projectiles we have a great
video up by dave jewett called how do
bullets work in games
so without consistent roles between or
even within mini games
it winds up being a lot of trial and
error and speaking of consistency if a
sniper rifle is there to hit the first
shot that means you need to see what
you're shooting at so now we're going to
talk about scopes
scopes it gets weird again we're not
going to go into the full science of
long-range shooting because it's kind of
a lot
but if you don't know scopes don't just
magnify things they have dots or
lines inside depending on the system
that correspond to
certain ranges you can use that to
figure out where to aim
some games like battlefield 4 kind of
fudge this they do let you dial your
scope to a specific range meaning you
don't have to aim high or low if you do
it right
the bullet will just go to the center of
the crosshair at the proper distance but
without some universal set of physics in
the game
and having different rifles with their
characteristics being tweaked
individually
the information inside of scopes just
flat out doesn't work in many cases like
if your target is x number of yards away
and you put the right dot or line on
your scope corresponding to that range
the bullet won't go where it's supposed
to which is good enough for gaming i
guess
it just leads to a lot of miss first
shots so with all that complexity you'd
think there would be a scope out there
that would simplify things
and there is and developers rarely use
it the dragon off scope for example has
a simple chart based on the height of an
average man
if you put the average five foot seven
person on that chart it gives you the
range
it's pretty simple and easy and honestly
kind of a pet peeve of mine that it's
not used in games
you have some other really fun problems
with scopes like draw distance but we'll
get into that in another video
alright that is the long range problem
now let's get to the good stuff
small maps why do games like call of
duty even pretend sniper rifles belong
on small maps
no modern sniper would ever get that
close because they'd be outmatched by
any other type of gun
and to balance that out developers
decided to make sniper rifles
insanely overpowered at close ranges
like in call of duty somehow players
with sniper rifles can take someone down
without ever looking through the scope
for the person behind the trigger it's
immensely satisfying
and i'll give it to you it makes for
great highlights on twitch or youtube
for everyone else
it is a cheap death oddly it's the same
problem we talked about earlier with
sniper rifles being overpowered and
killing players before they can react at
long ranges
only instead of developers balancing it
out with scopeland or breath control
they just said screw it and double down
on that imbalance
and let's be honest at those ranges
that's not a sniper rifle
it's stealing the role of a shotgun
which is nuts because too many games
make shotguns
kill in more than one hit at close range
that's the range where shotguns are
massively lethal
so i can only conclude that sniper
rifles have one purpose on small maps
and that's to make people mad that they
got instantly killed by a sniper rifle
or you know psychological warfare
asserting dominance depends on which end
of the gun you're on
[Music]
so what happens when you play sniper
rifles in their intended role it's kind
of a mixed bag
good players can make a big difference
despite the drawbacks you can hold off a
ridgeline of enemy snipers or win a
match of warzone you can drop the
enemy's best players or shut down a long
distance lane on a map
on the flip side sniper rifles can be so
much fun that half your team takes the
role
selfishly uses the helicopter to get to
their sniper's nest leaving you stranded
on an aircraft carrier as they head to
the back of the map to ignore the
objective and lose the entire match
for example
for those of you who do long range
shooting we probably didn't get
everything right in this video so feel
free to hop in the comments and teach us
some things
for more coverage of shooters including
a battlefield game this year make sure
to head on over to gamespot's youtube
page and
make your voice heard this idea came
from saunder on our last video
alright thanks for watching
[Music]
you